Transcriber: Marwa Ahmed
المدقّق: Aya Ashraf
هي ليست أول سيدة تحكم مصر،
ولم تسرق الحكم من ابن أخيها.
هي ليست قوية ومسترجلة،
ولا سلبية وضعيفة.
هي ليست أي شيء من هذه الأشياء.
هل عرفتم عن من أتحدث؟
أتحدث عن حتشبسوت.
ربما الكلام الذي قلته في البداية
جعلكم مترددين هل هي حتشبسوت أم لا.
وذلك لأن كل هذا الكلام معروف عنها.
ولكن ولا شيء من هذا الكلام صحيح.
لأنه من غير المعقول أن نقول على
كل امرأة ناجحة
أنها قوية ومسترجلة وسرقت حق ليس من حقها.
في الواقع، من وجهة نظري، كعالمة مصريات
أستطيع أن أقول لكم أن حتشبسوت
بإختيارتها وانجازاتها،
وعلى الرغم من كل المفاهيم الخاطئة حولها،
استطاعت أن تكون  شخصية مؤثرة
لأجيال كتير بعدها.
كانت ابنة ملك،
أميرة ولكن ليست كأي أميرة.
كانت آخر سلالة أحمس؛
ولذلك كانت هي المسؤولة عن حماية العائلة،
وحماية العرش.
بعد وفاة والدها اضطرت أن تتزوج
من أخاها غير الشقيق؛
لكي تحافظ على العرش.
وهذا ما جعلها بعد وفاة زوجها
تعين ابنه تحتمس الثالث وريث على العرش،
وهي الواصية عليه.
وبهذا فعلت مثل كل السيدات
اللاتي حكمن مصر قبلها.
حيث أنها لم تكن أول سيدة تحكم مصر.
حكم مصر قبل ذلك سيدات كثيرات،
ولكن بطريقة غير مباشرة.
كن دائمًا وصيات على العرش،
إلى أن يكبر الابن ويتولى الحكم.
لكن هناك ما فرّق حتشبسوت
عن كل السيدات من قبلها.
حتشبسوت استمرت.
بعد سبع سنوات من حكمها مع تحتمس الثالث،
قررت أنها تلقب نفسها
بملكة مصر العليا والسفلى.
ملكة مصر بشمالها وجنوبها.
غالبًا هذا ما جعل ناس كثيرة تقول
أنها قوية ومسترجلة.
ولكن هذا الكلام غير حقيقي.
لأنها لم تكن مضطرة إلى أن تنتظر سبع سنوات
حتى تتولى الحكم.
هي كانت بالفعل مُتحكمة في كل شيء.
غير ذلك، هي كانت مصرة على تذكير الناس
أن تحتمس الثالث هو وريث العرش،
وأنه ما زال موجود.
كانت تشركه في بعثاتها التعدينية في سيناء،
وحملاتها العسكرية في النوبة.
وكانت دائمًا حريصة على
تصوير صورته إلى جانب صورتها،
وهما يُقدمان القرابين للآلهة،
سواء في معبدها بالدير البحري،
أو في معبد الكرنك.
فهي كانت أم له
على الرغم من أنها ليست والدتع البيولوجية.
ربما كان هناك الكثير من الناس يقولون
عليها أيضًا أنها قوية ومسترجلة؛
لأنها بدأت بتصوير نفسها بهيئة رجل.
ولكن اعتقد أن سيدات كثيرات ممن يشاهدن
هذا الفيديو يمكنهن أن يفهمن السبب.
أحيانًا كثيرة نضطر إلى تغيير هيئتنا؛
حتى  تتناسب مع توقعات المجتمع.
وهذا ما فعلته حتشبسوت.
ومثلما كانت حتشبسوت غير تقليدية في هيئتها،
كانت أيضًا غير تقلدية
في السياسة اللي اتبعتها.
على عكس كل ملوك الأسرة الذين سبقوها،
كانت حتشبسوت مهتمة أكتر بالناس.
كل قراراتها وكل المعابد اللتي بنتها
كانت ضمن خطة أكبر وشبكة أكبر؛
كي تربط كل المعابد ببعض،
للاحتفالات الدينية،
والتي كانت شيئًا مهمًا جدًا.
لأن الاحتفالات الدينية التي بدأت
أن تكون أكثر رسمية وقتها،
وبدأن تاخد شكل ومواعيد ثابتة
من السنة إلى السنة في وقت حتشبسوت،
كانت الفرصة الوحيدة للناس
للتقرب من الملك والتقرب من الآلهه.
وهذا ما فعلته حتشبسوت.
ومثلما شملت الناس،
شملت أيضًا الموظفين الحكوميين.
في هذا الوقت استطاع الموظفون
بمختلف درجاتهم
أن يضعوا تماثيلهم في موكب هذه الاحتفالات،
حتى عندما يتذكرهم أبناؤهم وأحفادهم كل عام
وهم يشاركون في الاحتفالات
تظل سيرتهم سنوات وسنوات بعدها.
ومثلما كانت مهتمة بالناس،
كانت مهتمة أيضًا برجال الدولة.
ولكن كانت مهتمة بهم لمواهبهم وإنجازاتهم،
أكثر من كونهم من عائلات هامة أو ثرية.
وذلك لأن كثير جدًا من رجال الدولة وقتها
كانت عائلتهم بسيطة، أو حتى من الأقاليم.
ولكنهم استطاعوا أن يترقوا ويحصلوا على
ألقاب وامتيازات لم يسبقهم أحد إليها.
وغير ذلك، كانت مهتمة برجال الدولة
بغض النظر عن خلفياتهم الثقافية.
فأمراء النوبة مثلًا لم يكونوا
مجرد تابعين لها،
يدفعون لها الجزية والهدايا
في أوقات معينة من السنة.
لا، لأنهم كان لهم مناصب مهمة جدًا،
وكانوا قريبين جدًا من الملكة.
وذلك لم يكن ضعفًا منها، أو لكي تتودد لهم.
لا، فقد كانت بالفعل أرسلت
مناوشات عسكرية للنوبة.
ولكنها قررت ألا تركز على
التوسعات العسكرية،
وأن تركز أكثر على الناس.
وبهذا انشأت اتجاهًا قلدها فيه
الكثير من الملوك بعدها.
أشهرهم أمنحوتب الثالث.
والذي يعتبر أكثر ملك بنى معابد
في تلك الفترة،
وكان أيضًا يركز أكثر على الناس.
ولكن لا يسمع أحد عن أمنحوتب الثالث
أنه كان ضعيفًا وسلبيًا؛
لأنه لم يبعث بحروب للخارج.
لكن بالطبع حصلت حتشبسوت على نصيبها
من الإشاعات.
بدءًا من أنها ضعيفة وسلبية، وصولًا إلى
علاقتها بأكبر رجال الدولة سننموت.
وما أكد للناس هذا الكلام الآن
أن تماثيلها واسمها اتمحوا من بعد موتها.
لكن بالرغم من أن تماثيلها واسمها
اتمحوا بالفعل.
إلا أن أثرها ما زال باقيًا.
وذلك لأن بصمتها في المكان ظلت موجودة.
كل الملوك الذين جاؤا بعدها
بدؤا من ما تركته وأكملوه.
سواء معبد الكرنك أو المعابد الجنائزية
التي بنوها في البر الغربي.
كل هذا لم يكن ليحدث
لولا أن حتشبسوت استمرت.
كان عندها فرصة مثلها مثل
كل الملكات من قبلها.
ولكنها استغلت تلك الفرصة.
كانت واثقة من نفسها، وتعرف قيمتها.
حصلت على الفرصة،
فاستطاعت أن توفر فرص متكافئة
لكثير جدًا من الناس.
وهذه هي النسوية من وجهة نظري.
النسوية ليست صراع  بين النساء والرجال.
النسوية هي دعوة لوجود فرص متكافئة
بغض النظر سيدة أم راجل،
بغض النظر عن السن، أو المستوى الاجتماعي،
أو حتى الخلفية الثقافية.
وبهذا، من وجهة نظري، أستطيع لأن أقول لكم
أن حتشبسوت هي أم النسوية.
لأنها آمنت بكل ذلك.
حققت لنفسها الفرصة،
فاستطاعت أن تحققها لغيرها.
أنتِ أيضًا تستطعين أن تستمري،
وتستطيعين أن تحققي لنفسك الفرصة.
إذا لم يكن عندك الفرصة، اخلقيها لنفسك.
كوني مثل حتشبسوت.
ثقي بأنوثتك ومعجزاتها.